now that you have finished running the
rnac pipeline along with the
differential gene expression option we
can take a look at what are the various
outputs that we get so here in the
download folder you have many types of
expression tables first of all there are
gene expression table and isoform
expression table we provide these
expression tables in fpkm and in raw
reads apart from that you will also have
several visualization plots including ma
plot and volcano plot
now below you'll also see various
visualization options
so one is
to see if our reads are of good quality
we can take a look at the multi-quality
report online for quality assurance
and another important visualization
option is the gene expression that have
been expressed in the fpkm values and it
has been represented in the form of a
histogram and on the top you can also
see the gene expression of the sample
represented in the form of a box plot
we can also look at other graphs and see
what they say about our samples here we
can see the
overall gene expression of our samples
represented in the form of a box plot
another important visualization is that
of the heat map
and we also have an interactive volcano
plot with the significantly expressed
genes depicted in red color
finally we also have an external
dashboard that allows all the tables and
graphs to be maintained in a shareable
format
this also contains all the important
graphs and tables such as volcano plot
and heat map that we have discussed
previously